well science is telling us that we can
do phenomenal things if we put our minds
and our resources to it I mean I think
science is probably the best example of
you put resources into something and you
let the creativity and the brilliance of
the minds throughout the world and
certainly not only in this country
throughout the world and phenomenally
good things can happen you've got to
make sure that there's checks and
balances on that because science can
also lead to things that are not so good
you know and there's the whole ethical
issues of manipulating at the genomic at
the genomic level the whole issues of
embryos and creating people to your own
fashionable boutique liking all those
things you've got to really be very very
careful at but science at its most pure
where you're sweet looking for discovery
and you're going to use discovery for
the betterment of mankind I think
science stands out among what some of
the most important endeavors that the
humankind can pursue mankind evolves I
mean there's no doubt that we have
evolved the whole issue of evolving
through various lower species to our own
species of the human but there's also
the continuing evolution that is
associated with mankind and a lot of
that is using what specifically and
particularly and peculiarly makes you a
human being
and that is your intellect and your will
you have a choice you can analyze things
and you can act in an intellectual
manner and that is to me that the very
foundation of what science is how you
can better your own lot the lot of the
other citizens of the world while you're
paying attention to and preserving the
world you live in which is the reason
why things like the environment are so
so important when we try and analyze all
we doing things that are detrimental to
the environment and if so how do we stop
it and if we have to stop it how do we
replace it with something that's
environmentally free
and I think science is going to lead us
there and it's the goodwill that you
have to try and preserve your own
species as well as preserve the
environment ie our planet so that we can
have thousands of more years of people
doing good things in leading good lives
bioethics is a very very important field
we as as we get more and more in the
arena of understanding science and
getting better opportunities the fact
that you can do things with biological
sciences that have an impact on a human
being means you must have ethical
standards and and paramount among these
are when you do something that involves
a human subject as one example there are
a lot of bioethical issues but for
example if you're trying to develop a
new drug or a new vaccine and you need
to do experimentation there has to be
some fundamental immutable principles of
ethics that guide what you can and
cannot do when you're dealing with
another human being
and there are also fundamental things
that you can it cannot do when you're
dealing with life itself
I mean is it or is it not ethical to
create an embryo and to create a person
for the purpose of getting an organ to
give to someone else I mean your
knee-jerk reaction is absolutely not
but you need the ethical analysis of
that to show why and how that is
something that you need to stay away
from so I think that bioethics is one of
the most important evolving fields that
we have because as science gets more and
more sophisticated and as the
opportunities for transforming
Biological Sciences occur we're going to
be faced with more and more important
ethical questions and we can approach
that by the seat of our pants we have to
have experts who study that and make
that a career of analyzing the kinds of
ethical issues and gaining experience so
that when people come in and they're
faced with a question of ethics in the
biological sciences at least you have a
catcher of people who pay serious
attention to that